we're not done
you know you got to come with me here we
go
everybody oh man
everybody
that we can stay or what no
when i say everybody that would mean
that means everybody where are we going
whatever the godfather tell us man
listen man y'all helping me dude we have
to finish this off oh i see in the way
that we um the only way we possibly can
i think i know what this is going on i i
don't even know this i know what it is
oh here it is i can figure this out
because truckster i got the keys
and they're yours
you're the bus driver
oh my god oh
we're done we're done with the show
tonight so
oh lord you can take us home
it's the chuck wagon
hey yes we do have a bus
bus
y'all got a real [ __ ] help y'all got
nothing else to do we got nothing else
to do well put it like this if i'm on
the bus i'm going to give directions
because he'll have the directions
oh lord come on seriously did we zach
you're getting on the bus yeah yeah come
on come on we're on the bus we got the
bus driver oh
the door's open oh my god
oh man you got it sounded like you got
some experience here
oh
come on shaq get in zach get on the bus
you've been on bus rider before you been
on behind the bus
you didn't roll the bus
he said here he comes uh wearing the hot
dog hat come on in
y'all y'all are way over the top hey the
horns don't work
you know you know how to uh you know how
to do this here we go all right
yo tell them to open the gate oh who's
at the gate
don't worry about the gate chuckster
don't worry about it you can just take
it out man oh don't take the gator yeah
he can oh my god here we go
and that's a wrap for inside the nba
presented by kia
[Music]
for shaq and penny and the bus driver
hey don't go out on the road man ernie
johnson
we'll see you tomorrow i hope
oh my god
y'all look crazy man